happy birthday kate middleton
kensington palace released three
timeless regal and stunning photographs
of the duchess of cambridge on saturday
ahead of her 40th birthday on sunday
[Music]
according to the palace the portraits
were taken in november at kew gardens by
photographer paolo reversi the photos
will become part of the collection of
the national portrait gallery which is
set to reopen in
2023 communities across the uk will have
the opportunity to view the stunning
photographs in person as they will be
featured in the gallery's coming home
project which the palace dubbed as quote
a nationwide initiative which sees
portraits of well-known individuals
being sent to locations which they are
closely associated with that's really
what matters to me kate who was shown in
the portraits wearing jewelry that once
belonged to princess diana chose three
meaningful locations where she would
like her photos to appear berkshire in
south england st andrews in scotland and
anglesey an island off the coast of
wells it is a milestone birthday it's an
important birthday and when it comes to
how the duchess of cambridge is
celebrating the big 40 royal expert
katie nicholl tells e.t she thinks the
celebration will be pretty low-key and
might even include kate baking her own
cake i think there will be a celebration
but i think it will be
a celebration for family and for close
friends and there was talk of a of a big
party which has apparently been
downscaled because of covenant because
of the restrictions
but i suspect um that that kate is
probably happier having something a
little bit more low-key she had a big
21st birthday um but i think that was
the last big birthday that she really
really celebrated i know that williams
sometimes gets in the kitchen but really
kate kate is the master chef and she's
also brilliant at baking cakes so i
wouldn't be at all surprised if she
bakes her own birthday cake cakes have
always been a big tradition
in the middleton family kate has
revealed how on the nights before her
children's birthdays she's often up late
into the night and posting the final
touches to a birthday cake so i can't
imagine it'll be a shockboard cake for
kate i'm sure she'll be making it
herself
[Music]